Processed food industry was created by the cigarette industry.
People don't know this, but in 1990,
the three largest processed food companies were cigarette companies.
Philip Morris, RJ Reynolds,
and others still to this day.
Philip Morris owns craft.
Most of the companies were spun out in the 1990s,
but cigarette companies literally took their scientists.
Cigarettes companies were declining
and put them over to food companies to make the food more addictive.
And all those thousands of ingredients that we have in our food
are made to addict our children.
It's hijacking our biology and our understanding of, like,
what we're reading. You don't binge on natural food because the.
Our bodies are made over thousands of years to be with this food.
Yeah, but processed food is not natural.
It's hijacking our biology.